and now as far as we can tell it looks
like outrageous and even perhaps
murderous behavior by Minneapolis police
officers
another black man in police custody
gasping for air on the ground
defenseless and then shortly thereafter
dead
it's absolutely infuriating and
heartbreaking it's hard for just people
to watch it at all I was thinking today
this this means a lot of things but it
means that many young african-americans
many of them just starting out in their
lives end up thinking once again that
our criminal justice system is not just
rigged against them it's targeting them
now President Trump was right to jump on
this situation almost immediately
directing the DOJ and FBI to launch a
civil rights investigation into the
matter
obviously Attorney General FBI and the
Attorney General to take a very strong
look and to see what went on because
that was a very very bad thing that I
saw let me be really clear here no one
in America should feel like he or she is
being treated unfairly by law
enforcement because of skin color or any
other characteristic for that matter
tolerating anything but equal justice
under the law and due process it's
simply unacceptable you have every
absolute right to be angry to be upset
to be mad to express your anger however
you have no right to perpetrate violence
and harm on the very communities that
you say that you are standing up for now
in the year 2020 it's fairly obvious
that we need to ensure that there is
more protection for civil liberties
across the board for criminal suspects
held by authorities and for protesters
whether they're in Minnesota or in
Michigan our communities our
constitutional rights and frankly our
national soul are all at stake here yet
as we've seen time and again what began
as peaceful protesting ended up in a
very counterproductive and even
place
[Applause]
[Music]
get bad actors threw gasoline on the
fire figuratively and literally and
suddenly the message of justice for all
is not only lost its obliterated
peaceful protest is good it advocates
our rights and it also calls forth the
witnesses at the United States Attorney
watch this come forth
violence is not files hampers our case
it takes valuable police resources away
from our investigation and it also harms
innocent people who had nothing to do
with that it gets in the way of our work
FBI
and of course police on the scene trying
to quell people's concerns today and
answer them but excusing criminal
behavior as somehow justified when its
carried out in response to police
brutality or any other abuse only ends
up making a bad situation worse because
it lowers the bar for everybody it's
frankly patronizing and even demeaning
and it hurts more innocent people in the
community in the process have we
forgotten what happened during the Obama
years in Baltimore while we tried to
make sure that they were protected from
the cars and the other you know things
that were going on we also gave those
who wished to destroy space to do that
as well an outbreak of violence and
looting sparked by the death of a man in
police custody things did take a turn
today in Baltimore and there was many
hours today of rioting and looting
burning cars and tonight the fires can
turn yeah continue in Baltimore but they
had to give space to the rioters and
have we forgotten what happened in
Ferguson disappointment frustration
anger demonstrated as demonstrators
hitting the streets again with protests
erupting for a second night in Ferguson
police are now asking that all protests
occur during daylight hours
this after two new shootings overnight
one involving police now the national
media swooped in before all the facts
were known entire city blocks were
torched people's lives ruined and race
relations and crime got worse not better
in those cases the police were cleared
wrongdoing including by the Obama
Justice Department in the case of the
officer who shot and killed Michael
Brown now in the death of George Floyd
we have faith that our judicial system
will proceed carefully and smartly
we have to do this right we have to
prove it in a court of law and I will
just point to you the comparison to what
happened in Billy in Baltimore and the
gray case it was a rush to charge it was
a rush to justice and all of those
people were found not guilty
I will not rush justice because justice
cannot be rushed now I'm not going to
pretend for a millisecond to know what
it's like to be a black person in
America I don't but the only thing I do
know is that we all need to do better we
need to love more we need to respect
more do better while the wheels of
justice turn in this case it's important
that we also push back against the
notion that all police officers can
never be trusted or that America just a
you know at its core is some cauldron
boiling over with pure racism and
inequality America isn't hopeless she's
not irredeemable the overwhelming
majority of Americans just want to live
in peace they want to live in harmony
with their neighbors of all races and
all ethnicities most Americans are good
people and most police officers want to
help not hurt time and again we see that
the real change agents in America are
those who have stay in their communities
and build them up not burn them down
Rosa Parks is a beloved global symbol of
freedom and justice because of the
determination and dignity with which she
carried out her civil disobedience wood
burning a store have been more powerful
and transformative I don't think so and
to our african-american fellow citizens
I say this given his own experience with
an out-of-control FBI and unfair
investigations given all his work now on
criminal justice reform President Trump
knows how poisonous an out-of-control
law enforcement process can be we should
spend more time trying to work together
to ensure that we have a fair and just
society all human beings have inherent
worth all of them are endowed by God
with certain inalienable rights
from the evidence available thus far it
looks like George Floyd was denied his
and that's the angle